[Applaudissements]
je suis venu vous parler du monde
d'après et si vous parlez de systèmes de
normes de standards de choses qui sont
pas très drôle vous rappeler aux débuts
du confinement il ya deux ans une
éternité
ce monde d'après on a parlé on aurait
peut-être pu écouter michel houellebecq
vous savez il avait dit le monde d'après
ne vous précipitez pas ce sera le monde
d'avant empire
pourtant ce monde d'après on en a rêvé
on y avait d'ailleurs pensé un tout
petit peu avant le confinement
rappelez-vous 2015 une éternité avant
l'éternité en 2015 des accords de paris
sur le climat bien sûr quelques mois
auparavant à new york en septembre nous
étions mis d'accord sur les objectifs
développement durable c'est le pin's que
je porte ici que les français
connaissent pas beaucoup mais qui est
une référence mondiale on s'est mis
d'accord en 2015 sur ce monde d'après on
a choisi de vivre ensemble une économie
qui soit durable qui soit inclusive qui
soit résiliente tous les états ont
souscrit tous les états ont souscrit
nous sommes engagés pourtant on n'y est
pas on le sent bien on sent ce monde qui
craque on voit la guerre en ukraine la
crise pandémique pour certains c'est les
années 30 avec la montée des fascismes
et autoritarisme pour d'autres c'est les
années 70 avec la conjugaison de
l'inflation de la récession la
stagflation en tout état de cause ce ne
sont pas des références très
intéressante très agréable très
motivante
il est donc bien temps de se poser cette
question de revenir sur ce monde d'après
qui nous appartient de bâtir de répondre
enfin à ces questions mais au fond dans
quelle économie voulons-nous vivre et
une fois qu'on a répondu à cette
question comment voulons-nous la
financer et finalement comment
voulons-nous vivre ensemble sur cette
planète alors pour ça un peu d'histoire
s'impose je vous ramène un siècle en
arrière fin de la première guerre
mondiale
on peut pas imaginer séquences plus
épouvantable que celle qui nous amène de
1918 à 1945 la paix est raté la grippe
espagnole n'avait oublié ça nous a été
rappelée à quelques quelques années le
krach de 1929 on rate absolument tout
l'humanité s'enfonce dans les ténèbres
ont fini par une guerre mondiale en 1944
45 sous égide américaine et de ce côté
du rideau de fer on rebâtit un système
un système organisé c'est des accords de
bretton-woods création du fonds
monétaire et d'un banque mondiale où
j'ai servi création de l'otan on se
rappelle maintenant à quoi ça sert
création des nations unies plus tard
création l'union européenne pas toutes
ces institutions qui vivent encore et
qui illustre les trente glorieuses pour
notre pays ce système il est organisé
autour des états unis il est organisé
autour du dollar lui-même convertible en
or d'un point de vue économique ce
système il tient bon il est plutôt
positif jusqu'à ce qu'il craque ce sont
les débuts des années 70
deux dates 13 septembre 1970 c'est là
qu'on bascule dans le système qui est le
nôtre aujourd'hui milton friedman
bientôt prix nobel d'économie fait un
article retentissant dans le new york
times il doit répondre à la question est
ce que general motors à l'époque plus
grandes entreprises aux athlètes et à ce
titre extrêmement symbolique doit
accepter dans son tour de table à son
conseil d'administration trois
représentants du public interest ce
qu'on appellerait les parties prenantes
aujourd'hui réponse de friedman non ce
serait du socialisme chimiquement pur et
déjà à l'époque le mot socialiste est un
très très gros mot aux états unis du
socialisme chimiquement pur l'objet
social de l'entreprise est d'accroître
ses profits or l'article était plus
riche que ça mais on a retenu sa
quelques mois plus tard le 15 août 1971
richard nixon signe l'acte décès des
trente glorieuses en dix ans le dollar
n'est plus convertible en or
c'est pas ton ça qui est intéressant
c'est le fait qu'on bascule dans un
système où maintenant si je vous demande
combien vaut un dollar vous allez me
reçoivent autant d'euros ils formidable
un euro ça vaut combien bassa votants de
dollars et puis ça change tous les jours
c'est ce qu'on a appelé pardonnez moi
être un peu simpliste pour les experts
ici le mark to market nous sommes entrés
dans un système où on pense marché c'est
le marché qui donne la valeur ce système
il a trouvé son éclosion politique avec
l'élection de reagan et thatcher à la
fin des années 70 le consensus de
washington le modèle néolibéral la
révolution conservatrice tout ça nous
amène à 1989 la chute du mur de berlin
la fin de l'histoire croyons-nous à
l'époque et pourtant c'est pas comme ça
que ça s'est passé le modèle a eu ses
vertus phase de croissance très forte on
a tiré une partie du monde de la
pauvreté notamment en chine mais ce
modèle se heurte en 2007-2008 à une
grave crise financière qui n'est pas
complètement un accident cette crise
financière c'est d'abord une crise de
l'innovation d'une finance qui est un
peu sorti de sable taye et qui innovent
pour le plaisir d'innover une finance
qui a perdu un peu le sens de son métier
de son utilité c'est une crise de la
régulation ce n'est pas un accident le
modèle tel qu'il s'est imposé dans les
années soixante dix et quatre vingts
c'est un modèle de régulation légère ce
que les anglo-saxons appellent litetouch
régulation le marché se régule tout seul
c'est bien ça le fondement de notre
réflexion et ceux ci une crise de la
mondialisation d'un côté vous avez
mondialisation financière et
technologique qui va très vite sans
frein et de l'autre une modélisation
juridique et éthique qui avance à petit
pas ce système se déchire en 2008 avec
la faillite de lehman brothers le
gouvernant la banque d'angleterre de
l'époque dit la mondialisation a vécu
avant lehman est une entreprise mondiale
le jour elle fait faillite elle
redevient américaine
pressentiment intéressant quand on voit
le contexte d'aujourd'hui
on a un sursaut en 2015 gelé dire notre
oduction on se met quand même d'accord
sur cette feuille de route pour réparer
on n'a pas toucher aux fondamentaux
financiers mais on s'est dit allez on va
imaginer un monde plus durable plus
inclusif plus résilient la faiblesse du
raisonnement à l'époque mais j'en ai
fait partie et j'ai cru c'est qu'on
s'est pas posé la question du comment on
s'est pas posé la question du combien ça
coûte d'éradiquer la pauvreté combien ça
coûte de donner accès à l'eau à tout le
monde combien ça coûte la santé pour
tout le monde combien ça coûte la
révolution climatique on a fait des
chiffrages macro on s'est pas posé la
question de savoir si notre système
allait naturellement nous entraîner dans
la bonne direction on a pensé que le bon
vieux modèle friedmanien la main
invisible puisque l'objectif était bon
puisque barack obama jean ping c'était
serré la main tout ça allait nous
entraîner dans la bonne direction où en
sommes nous évidemment ça n'a pas marché
on arrive aujourd'hui crises pandémiques
crise sanitaire crise
sécuritaire ou géopolitiques après une
crise financière crise environnementale
qui n'est pas finie crise sociale dont
on voit bien autour de nous qu'elle est
là ces crises elles sont présentes ces
crises d'une certaine manière elle
montre en creux qu'on n'a pas traité
après la crise financière des lignes de
faille du modèle dans lequel on existe
aujourd'hui c'est crise nous oblige à
nous poser ses questions et elles sont
préoccupantes en particulier pour nous
occidentaux petites références
littéraires si vous l'autorisez me gurit
tueur sonar dans les mémoires d'hadrien
imagine devient empereur adrien méditant
sur la chute de rome adrien se dit je
sais qu'elle va venir je sais que la
chute de rome d'avenir comment puis-je
la retarder comment puis-je retarder ce
moment où les barbares au dehors et les
esclaves au dedans se rueront sur un
monde qu'on leur demande de respecter de
loin ou de servir d'en bas
de respecter de loin et de servir d'en
bas c'est dans ce contexte que ces
crises se passe c'est dans ce contexte
qu'on n'a pas été à la hauteur de ce
qu'a été posée en 2015 donc on nous
sommes à ce moment un peu compliqué
notre histoire collective où les
tensions s'accumulent accélération des
inégalités accélération du numérique
accélération de tous les côtés et ce
modèle qui craque et qui n'est pas à la
hauteur des attentes qu'on a posé il ya
maintenant sept ans
on se rend compte pourtant qu'il faut
changer que les changements sont
globalement irréversible mais qui sont
coûteux beaucoup plus que ce qu'on
croyait on pensait qu'en changeant un ou
deux pour cent par an pendant 30 ans
d'aller se réveiller finalement tout
irait bien non ça va être compliqué ça
va être coûteux on se rend compte que
finalement pour parler fond de lui il
faut toucher à notre pricing système il
faut abandonner l'idée que le profit est
une fin en soi que l'objet social
entreprise c'est le profit non le profit
n'est pas une fin en soi le profita
moyens en vue d'une fin permettez moi de
citer un professeur d'oxford colline
mayer qui a cette très belle formule
l'objet social de l'entreprise
n'est pas d'accroître son profil objet
social de l'entreprise c'est de trouver
des solutions profitables
pour résoudre les problèmes de cette
planète et de ses habitants car pour
l'instant il n'y a pas d'autres planète
et ses habitants c'est nous tous il y en
a pas d'autre c'est bien ça redonner du
sens au profit alors évidemment c'est
pas dire qu'il ne s'est rien passé
depuis six ans on a inventé une
magnifique comme les anglo saxons
alphabètes soupe une soupe d'acronymes
on parle d'investissement socialement
responsable et sert de pratiques esg
environnement ce environnemental social
et gouvernance
on part de frs et ssv internacional
sustainability standaard board exeter
vous entendez tout ça dont il se passe
des choses je veux pas dire qu'il ne se
passe rien mais on voit bien qu'on est
encore au bord qu'on est encore dans le
déclaratif dans l'aspi rationnel dans ce
qu'on appelle les meilleurs efforts on
se dit ben oui je vais faire un peu
combien ça va me coûter jusqu où je vais
aller et on se rend bien compte que
c'est pas suffisant on se rend bien
compte que c'est pas exactement le sujet
qu'on n'est pas à la hauteur de ce qu'on
a posés sur la table et quelques années
que ce monde d'après on le fera pas en
tâtonnant on le fera pas à peu près et
c'est très difficile et c'est très
douloureux et en plus ya la guerre qui
vient perturber tout ça le coc vie nous
a montré ce que ça coûte et de baisser
les émissions de carbone d'arrêter
l'économie complètement en 2020 la crise
avec l'ukraine nous montrent bien la
question de l'énergie aujourd'hui vous
voit bien que c'est difficile de se
passer de gaz donc on voit bien on est
face à nos contradictions celle-ci se
cristallise autour de nous donc on est
en ce moment très délicat où on sent
bien qu'il faut aller plus loin c'est
difficile que c'est coûteux qu'on ne
sait pas bien faire on s'entoure dans un
certain brouillard où finalement on ne
sait pas où on va aller et souvent ce
que j'entends c'est que dans le
brouillard on se replie sur son jardin
son entreprise son village sa famille sa
paroisse en disant écoutez tout ça me
dépasse le climat les réfugiés le risque
cyber j'y comprends rien au moins chez
moi je peux faire ce que j'aime ce que
j'appelais aux états unis retournez dans
l'ohio au now in order contrairement à
la california ca collective action
action collective eh bien oui c'est vrai
que si tu sais america firth est
exactement tout ça qui était en germe
avant le coc vide en germe avant la
guerre et qui est renforcée donc
aujourd'hui on est où vivent dans le
brouillard il ya trois attitudes vous
êtes dans une voiture dans le brouillard
vous faites marche avant marche arrière
ou point mort le point mort c'est le
statu quo c'est un peu la tentation
naturelle on en dise ne se passe rien
j'arrête et j'attends que le brouillard
se dissipe ça c'est très dangereux la
marche arrière c'est la régression c'est
dire votre façon de bien vu je l'avais
bien dit toutes ces histoires de climat
il faut remettre les centrales à charbon
en actions remettent du gaz tout ça on y
va non évidemment c'est parce que je
vais vous recommander il faut passer en
marche avant il faut retrouver son bon
sens il faut retrouver sa boussole alors
c'est compliqué parce qu'on voit bien on
n'a pas besoin de réinventer la poudre
honda la feuille de route elle était
adoptée en 2015 on l'a choisi en 2015
cette feuille de route
comment est-ce qu'on va de l'avant dans
un monde il n'y a pas de maître du monde
en 1970 les états unis avaient un
magistère intellectuelle avec les anglo
saxons en 1945 paraît aujourd'hui il n'y
a pas de magistère américain ya pas de
magistère européen il n'y a pas de
magistère chinois ils sont même en
compte laurence et c'est une concurrence
qui est compliqué parce que ce n'est pas
une concurrence sur des sujets
techniques on n'est pas en train de se
diviser sur des normes comptables pour
savoir s'il vaut mieux compter comme ci
comme ça on parle de valeurs qui va
déterminer les valeurs notre économie
est ce que ça va être décidé par les
chinois par blackrock par le parlement
européen au parlement dans nos
parlements français et je vais être très
concret c'est pas une vision l'esprit
parlons de diversité aux etats unis la
diversité ethnique c'est d'abord et
avant tout la diversité bornes c'est
d'abord et avant tout la diversité
ethnique et vous savez comme moi qu'en
france on ne peut pas recensés la
diversité ethnique loyale ce n'est pas
un débat qu'il faut avoir par ailleurs
est ce que ce débat doit être tranché
parce qu'on aura une mauvaise note de la
part de blackrock bloomberg ou est ce
qui doit être tranchée au parlement on
parle bien de valeur on parle pas de
technique et des exemples comme ça on
peut les lister les uns derrière les
autres donc c'est un sujet qui est très
compliqué sujets de concurrence et je
crois que l'europe elle a un rôle
particulier parce que l'europe et les
plus avancées sur ces questions de
développement durable les plus avancées
sur ces questions d'économie résiliente
elle est plus avancé sur ces questions
d'inclusion c'est important pour nous
qu'on nous impose pas d'extérieur monde
dont on ne veut pas mais c'est important
aussi pour toute une partie du monde qui
n'est pas parti dans ces débats je parle
du monde émergents et en développement
on ne peut pas être inclusif juste chez
nous on ne peut pas être inclusif entre
bobo on ne peut pas dire vu de chantilly
ou vu de paris voilà comment on voit la
planète et si vous m'aimez vous venez
avec moi si vous m'aimez pas c'est tant
pis pour vous il faut qu'on sache
capable de tendre la main à ces pays
émergents et en développement à les
intégrer dans cette discussion à
comprendre d'où ils partent et c'est
compliqué dans un monde où on est sur
notre jardin et le jardin de l'autre à
l'autre bout de la planète on n'en veut
pas on pense aux réfugiés à l'immigrant
etc ça nous intéresse pas non il faut
qu'on avait cette capacité la montée et
inventée ce monde d'après ensemble ne
devenons pas les bobos de la planète
c'est très important alors comment est
ce qu'on se projette dans ce monde
d'après j'ai pas d'arrêt j'ai pas le
mode d'emploi alors que la dé la
mondialisation et la gouvernance
mondiale sont plutôt en train de se
désagréger je pense qu'une partie de la
réponse elle est dans nos mains ici dans
cette salle est un peu partout la
gouvernance mondiale se désagrège
imaginez le g20 qui était à peu près ce
qui marche et le moins mal impossible
d'imaginer un g20 cette année avec la
chine la russie l'union européenne et
les etats unis ça ne marchera pas la
coop ça va être très compliqué comme en
egypte avec la famine autour de la coop
et savoir qui va participer sans les
russes sont les chinois ce qu'on va en
parler de l'avenir du climat difficile
donc on sent bien que tout ça nous
échappe un peu c'est pas pour ça qu'il
faut baisser les bras il y aura pas
dernière de la planète sont s'occuper du
jardin n'y aura pas d'avenir fois au
jardin ça on s'occupe pas de la planète
et c'est là qu'on a en tant que
consommateur en tant qu'investisseur en
tant que talent dans les entreprises une
capacité à faire entendre notre voix ne
regrettons pas ne pas l'avoir fait dans
20 ans alors si je peux conclure en
partageant avec vous les 12 points qui
me paraissent éclairer notre démarche
dans ce brouillard que je que j'ai un
peu d'écrits ce brouillard on se dit
mais est ce qu'il se passe quelque chose
est ce que finalement la finance nous a
pas encore une fois embobiner en nous
racontant qu'elle devenait durables et
vertes ou est ce qu'il ya vraiment un
changement ce changement sera réel si on
le pousse douze principes si vous voulez
pour pour garder à l'esprit comment on
peut encore créer ce monde d'après
premier principe et c'est contraire à
toutes les traditions françaises n'y
aura pas de grand soir on aime bien moi
je vais t français des organismes
internationaux vers les français ils
adorent les révolutions a et coupe les
têtes ils font table rase il près de la
bastille abolissent les privilèges ils
pensent que c'est réglé non ces sujets
là prennent du temps il faut être
ambitieux parce que c'est bien un
changement de système qu'il s'agit il
faut être modeste ça prend du temps
faire ça étape par étape point numéro un
deuxième point il faut être systémique
c'est à dire qu'on va pas prendre par
petits bouts on va faire un petit bout
de climat un petit bout de nature un
petit bout de social etc non je pense
qu'il faut vraiment prendre le seul
operating system il faut rentrer dans le
dur travail et nos normes comptables nos
modes de gouvernance ne des obligations
fiduciaires des gens qui gère votre
argent les modes de rémunération
transformer finalement ce système de
mark to market en mark to planète
renforcer rechange et tout tout ce
système de normes de standards pas par
petit bout mais tout ensemble
troisièmement ne pas jeter le bébé avec
l'eau du bain d'économie de marché c'est
l'optimisation arrêtons d'optimiser à
tout prix optimisons au mieux et en
incorporant l'idée de résilience de
capacité à faire face aux chocs c'est
très important quatrièmement il faut
apprendre à travailler publics et privés
ensemble chacun dans son silo ça ne
marchera pas aucun des dix sept
objectifs développement durable pas plus
que le climat ne seront des primes qui
seront résolus par le seul gouvernement
ou par les seules entreprises à gan
disait le gouvernement n'est pas la
solution c'est le problème cet idiot
pendant le coc vide on m'a dit
exactement contraire c'était idiot aussi
réapprenons à travailler ensemble c'est
important
la technologie quelque chose était aussi
c'est comme la finance est une force
extrêmement à la fois séduisante et
anxiogène on voit bien d'énergie qui a
des dents la dernière technologie
énergie cas vers la finance il faut que
cette technologie est en train de
transformer nos économies on la met au
service de ce modèle c'est important de
garder ça à l'esprit il faut garder
aussi l'idée que on a bien la finance au
service de l'économie et l'économie au
service de l'homme pas à linverse c'est
pas l'homme au service de la file et de
l'économie et l'économie au service de
la finance reparler de fraternité c'est
important se rappeler qu'il n'y aura pas
de valeur sans valeur sans mauvais jeu
de mots sans intégrité anecdotes paul
volcker qui avait combattu l'inflation
avait dit en 2000 à une conférence à
laquelle je participe et je n'accepte
pas plus en 2008 qu'en 1945 les excuses
de nuremberg voulait financier vous êtes
les plus diplômés vous êtes les mieux
payés de la planète me faites pas croire
en plus que vous ne savez pas ce que
vous faites ouvrons les yeux soyons un
teg ne faisons pas semblant ne pas
savoir ce qu'on fait très important
neuvièmement mur défensif c'est l'état
c'est la tentation je viens des états
unis on va pas faire des murs il faut
qu'on embrasse qu'on soit inclusive
c'est le message que je passais tout à
l'heure on ne va pas être on va pas se
sauver tout seul dans notre dans notre
jardin ça n'existe pas il faut aussi
qu'on réfléchisse à un autre système à
la mesure du système
là aussi c'est une question importante
nous sommes dans les normes et féret ce
pardon d'être compliqué on parle de pnb
il faut réviser nos instruments de
mesure passer d'un modèle où on mesure
la croissance un modèle on mesure le
développement il faut se rappeler que
développement durable c'est comme on
disait pudiquement laisser les toits
dans les quêtes dans l'état dans lequel
on l'a trouvé le développement durable
c'est pas d'essai à nos enfants un
passif environnemental un passif
financer un passif social il est temps
qu'on rééquilibre le bilan et qu'on
permette à nos enfants à leur tour de
faire les choix que nous n'avons pas
forcément su faire et dernièrement
évidemment on ne changera pas le monde
si on ne change pas soi-même tolstoï
l'adie infiniment mieux que moi tout le
monde changer le monde personne ne veut
se changer soi même le pouvoir il est
dans nos mains mais pour finir peut-être
une citation de jean giraudoux en 5
secondes dans la guerre de troie n'aura
pas lieu 1936 à méditer ulysse dit au
maire le privilège des grands et de
croire qu'il peut voir les catastrophes
depuis leur terrasse nous sommes sur la
terrasse faisons en sorte qu'il n'y ait
pas catastrophe et que s'il y en a une
on descendre et qu'on va traite merci
beaucoup
[Applaudissements]